[Music]
all right so much happening around the
globe
joining us now Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo mr. secretary always good to see
you and thank you for joining us good to
be with you all right Thank You Sean
thanks for having me on tonight we see
here's Venezuela with one of the largest
oil reserves in the world 80 percent
hyperinflation poverty bare necessities
chaos two presidents at once if you will
what's a situation and obviously your
position the president's position is
very important here so the president had
a chance a cue to speak with interim
president guado today the quest for
freedom is on and the Venezuelan people
have made very very clear that their
Constitution demands that Maduro not be
the Prez of the United States and the
United States is prepared to support the
Venezuelan people to achieve the freedom
democracy you talked about it this is a
so once knell thewhat wealthy nation
with enormous natural resources and yet
we have a humanitarian crisis we've got
three million refugees leave Venezuela
this is a catastrophe a man-made
catastrophe by the Maduro regime and
we're intent upon helping the Venezuelan
people correct it there's been a lot of
talk about a second summit with Kim
jong-un it's it's pretty amazing to me
the progress there because no more
rockets it was happening on a regular
basis being fired over Japan threatening
the entire region even threatening the
United States hostages have been
returned the remains of American
soldiers have been returned and
denuclearization talks continue what is
the status now of where those
negotiations are and when do you foresee
another summit so Shawn I think we'll
have a summit at the end of the month
that's the plan that's what the North
Koreans have now agreed to is what we've
agreed to with them as well we'll do it
someplace in Asia so I think that looks
good I'm dispatching a team there
they're headed that way now to lay the
foundations for what I hope will be a
substantial additional step towards the
path for not only denuclearization of
the peninsula but a brighter future for
the North Korean people and security on
the peninsula in a way that no previous
administration's been able to achieve I
think it took president Trump to
convince chairman Kim that that all the
commitments that he made this past June
in Singapore now
time for my team and all of the United
States government to work with the North
Koreans to execute that and to deliver
on our commitment to denuclearize the
peninsula chairman Kim has told us he's
prepared to do it and now the mission is
to deliver on that as the former
director of the CIA I would argue me and
you know a lot more than me that
intelligence gathering is probably more
of an art than necessarily a science
although some things are certain as
relates to intelligence interpretations
of Iranian capabilities you have the
president you have Prime Minister
Netanyahu maybe disagreeing with some of
the intelligence reports
I would chalk that up to maybe
interpretation but I'm guessing what do
you say yeah I think that's right I
don't think there's much dispute and
having had the chance to be the director
of the CIA I think the intelligence
supports that Iran presents a real risk
and that they have the capability to
enrich nuclear material fissile material
they have increase in capacities and
continue to work towards improving their
missile program just guess it was just
last week Sean that they attempted to
launch a space launch vehicle which
certainly would help them deliver on
their missile program these are all
components that lead us to a place where
they could one day have a system that
threatens America and president Trump's
made clear we're not going to tolerate
that we're not going to let Iran end up
where North Korea is today and we have a
set of policies in place to prevent that
last question is about Syria Afghanistan
American troops the president wants to
pull back on on troops we only have
about 2,000 and my understanding in
Syria some members of Congress some
members in the Senate have disagreement
is there a solution and what is the real
status of Isis is it degraded to the
point where it's not anywhere near the
threat it once was well the president
will make a significant announcement I
think in the State of the Union next
week with respect to the status of the
Caliphate the real estate the grounds
from which Isis had been operating in
Syria when this administration came in
you remember the prisoners in cages
people kneeling on the beaches and being
beheaded how this was tragic we also
know that it's
quite an enormous progress we've made in
the success that we've had that the
threat from radical Islamic terrorism is
real and we need to continue to do all
that we can to make sure that there's
not a resurgence of Isis or that all the
other variants of that terror regime
continue to be under pressure this
administration's committed to that
president Trump is has made clear it is
a priority for him and as the Secretary
of State I can promise the American
people we will continue to do all that
we can to keep them safe from this
threat one thing I always remembered in
the 9/11 report Commission report they
were at war with us we weren't at war
with them and we know that those
radicals are out there and what their
goals are mr. secretary thanks for
spending that time with us we appreciate
it
[Music]